there's gonna be drama there's gonna be
games there's gonna be music there's
gonna be it's an event
since the day I was alive my cookouts
have never been chilled the cookout to
me is like where black people come to be
blackity black let all their generations
get together teach like the older
generation as much as they teach you is
true a cookout is a safe place to be a
lot of friends of family the cookada is
the only place where you don't have two
coats which its immediate family
siblings aunts uncles cousins neighbors
family friends fake aunties fake uncles
it was my Haitian education school
that's why I learned about my culture my
music how to cook like the importance of
family members yeah you can't fight a
good girl people fight at the cookout
okay you're not supposed to let's see
what celebs are coming to our cookouts
hell no I can tell you that from the
jump the whole Kardashian clan she'd be
too much of a spectacle I think the
Kremlin's wouldn't stop talking about
the cornrows I'm not with it you know
about to be at my family cookout
embarrassing me hell nah but that i'ma
go like this she can come to the parking
lot to drop off the bait I'm doing this
for her sake because my family is very
intense
my family would just like talk crap and
like laugh and like joke and for some
people that's parapets and you know not
bring you nothing to help out and you're
not taking no place home with you you
know my place I'm have to go with no
Justin Timberlake Justin Timberlake you
want the outside Barbra there would be
peace in his potatoes plan right
postpone rolls free this last album just
look cool you know let me tell you why
you can't come to the cookout in my
opinion cuz I know exactly what's your
back it's all my okay
no I take it back no no after that Janet
situation I'm not friends
yeah you can't come to the cookout if
you're not protecting black you can't
what you did right you do what you do
use a part of it yeah I'm a cook um what
do you ask me that
why is that even an option Rachel went
around masquerading as a black woman you
sue the University for reverse racism we
don't do it we don't do that you're out
but be yourself
at the end of the day we can't say today
I want to be black today you know I
don't want we can't do that
black people discriminating against
white people doesn't prevent white
people from housing opportunities job
opportunities living literally being
alive they all know who she is then you
don't want no Haitian on their bad side
don't believe in encouraging bad
behavior yeah it's a note without maker
please hell no no that's it that's all I
say nope
Omarosa at one point was very like pro
black woman hard working for Trump
mitigated everything that she ever
worked for regarding this right
regarding black women I just it took it
all the way why
Omarosa has like a whole purview of
insight into a different view from my
family
therefore it could make for a very
interesting conversation you accepted
that invitation to that White House you
declined your invitation to propel right
no messing around right we not gonna
block her she yeah I feel like she's
like a really nice person
I guess fear like sitting around
chatting to my grandma you know like I
feel like she would be very like engaged
and like interested yeah you can't just
kind of take advantage of our culture
when you when you need it and then [ __ ]
on it the next day because you're
putting on the culture as a costume when
it's beneficial to you when it stops
being beneficial to you you take it off
nan POC people kind of like to show that
they know but I don't want my family and
my name to just be poster child no use
it to get ahead and
she was like actually I won't be myself
again right right
all you look like any is now I just
watched a video about is he
appropriating or not like maybe this is
my answer he appreciates he doesn't
appropriate he gives credit where credit
is due
no I don't kill it when we started down
a hundred first thing I wish you're
gonna do it I'll Bruno watch your drunk
uncle do the electric slide my family
does not be inside a cookout and I feel
like he could make it happen everybody
puts on his bike it makes music with
black on it
right throwing out building me think I'm
good I'm good
the whole Kardashian clan Kanye included
I love cookout so I want to cook out
right now it's a good unwind yeah busy
busy day doing like paranoid they're
working heavily come here my girl we're
more than a cooker hey Lisa
yeah can dr. Phil comb
no no oh my god I can't calm either
we're not fixing oh hi oh my god